there are hundreds of former prosecutors
who are now asserting that Donald Trump
obstructed justice that he committed the
crime of obstruction of justice and
we've been talking about this for some
time now it's been several weeks since
the bar letter and eventually the
redacted
Mulla report and we've been talking
about the fact that Robert Muller didn't
decide about indicted Ahnold Trump for
obstruction of justice Trump and William
bar and others have framed Robert
Moeller's decision not to indict for
obstruction of evidence for obstruction
of justice as evidence of exoneration
but Robert Moeller actually makes it
really really clear in the reports that
he is not exonerating Trump that he's
unable to exonerate Trump the terms
substantial evidence of obstruction by
Donald Trump is used in molars report
but what Muller does say is that for
political reasons including that
indicted a sitting president would
hamper their ability to carry out the
task of being president of the United
States
Moeller was going to leave the decision
about indictment to the Attorney General
who of course was selected by Trump and
immediately said oh yeah we're not
indicted Trump but Robert Muller's
decision not to indict Trump was a
political decision it's not a legal
decision based on the evidence and case
in point there are now more than 370
former federal prosecutors who have
worked for both Republican and
Democratic presidents who have signed
their names to a statement that politics
aside meaning like if you forget for a
second that we're talking about a
sitting president if you look at Trump
the person Trump the man Trump
homosapiens the evidence against Trump
for obstruction would lead to an
indictment for any other member of Homo
sapiens who did the stuff that Donald
Trump did Trump's Attorney General
William bar has been insisting that the
evidence doesn't suggest indictment
against Trump but more than 370 federal
prosecutors who have worked for
Republicans who over for Democrats but
more importantly are not currently
working for Donald Trump disagree
they're not saying to be very clear
Trump would be found guilty of
obstruction of justice
our federal prosecutors they understand
that Trump would get his day in court
and that there would be a trial and
maybe Trump would be found guilty and
maybe he wouldn't what the 370 federal
prosecutors are saying is that Trump
would be indicted on the basis of the
evidence and then it would go to trial
and Trump could defend himself and mount
the strongest legal defense possible
based on the evidence that the
indictment should have taken place
there's a Twitter user Yammer jaw who
has been doing some really great
visualizations of the Moller report and
actually did one for obstruction
obstruction has three elements was the
act obstructive was their corrupt intent
meaning that the person doing the
obstructive act knew that they were
acting improperly in order to obstruct
and third was the person aware that
there was something to obstruct in other
words were they aware that in this case
there was an investigation where by the
actions would be considered obstructive
of it there are fourteen possible
obstructive actions by Donald Trump and
we have them up on the screen for our
visual audience and Moeller found that
in eight of those fourteen Donald
Trump's actions met all three elements
of obstruction those eight are telling
Jim Comey to let Michael Flynn off the
hook
firing James Comey trying to fire Robert
Muller trying to focus the molar probe
only on future elections instead on what
Trump did which is laughable trying to
have Jeff Sessions take over the
investigation trying to influence Paul
manna Ford's dealings with robert muller
and publicly attacking michael cohen and
his family to influence his dealings
with muller and his testimony there are
eight counts of obstruction where
Moeller found all three elements that
are needed for obstruction to be present
and you have 370 former federal
prosecutors who are simply saying it's
very clear it's very clear if you read
the Moller report you understand this
most people don't read the Moller report
so it's very good to have lots of
prosecutors signing on to this in the
same way that debating impeachment of
the president in the House of
Representative
even if they don't move forward would be
such a great thing
merely to expose people who are either
in the Fox News echo chamber or who are
just busy living their lives and don't
have time to read a 450 page report like
people who work in this world have the
time or make the time to do expose the
reality that's the whole no collusion no
obstruction no indictment exoneration
narrative is public relations it's a
managed PR campaign and we have to do
what we can to publicize the content of
the Moller report period that's what
these prosecutors are doing they're
exactly right it takes only looking at
the Moller report and at what is said in
there about evidence to make that to
recognize and to understand why it is
that this is so important good for the
prosecutors and hopefully more people
will become aware not of propagandized
opinions about the report but simply
what is in the report because it truly
does speak for itself